got video games yeah hundred percent
alright so album no res a lot of sex
production definitely a whole bunch of
[__] six production I got some joints
on there one joint with no ID
yeah joint joint window ID for sure and
he like as executive producer was all
over it like you know just just guiding
all of us your chance you know saying
who else is on there or can you set this
one in the middle of the interview okay
can you tell just sorry just like it
sorry about that well cut it cut s1 who
produce power for cocky boo from
Atlantis just do it on a couple of he's
crazy who else is on their [__] Rob Knox
he produces a [__] like Denton gone for
Justin Timberlake and TI who am I
forgetting but I got a whole bunch of
people that are all on it take these for
TE even Tara's Martin from Nikki Terrace
Martin Atlanta reacts playing sax on
their smart this Bend oh yeah dogs yes
for a year for those young might not
know you know he did like real for kids
a good rapper oh he's great great
producer yo just musician overall um
taught me a lot about jazz features do
you have features like I know that was
kind of been done for a while right yeah
it's are the features are you gonna have
nozzle me oh that's funny then he said
listen you have to no idea you have the
no I D
cocaine eighties connection yeah yeah
you guys work out of the same dunno in
LA when I was before everyone knows that
no yeah he's a good dude honestly I was
with you know a cannon yeah of course
yeah the cat is such an underrated
produce no he's [__] incredible
so I was with him in the studio one day
and I was telling him how like I wanna
you know I've never met Kendra guy but I
had the opportunity but really you have
a big fan of Kendrick he was somebody I
thought would sound great on this type
of how along
everybody from car features locked down
yeah or there's no you know what it was
Canha was like [__] everybody any didn't
mean ain't no malicious may way he was
like man [__] everybody this is your
story bro and so even though there was a
lot of people I wanted to connect with
for even the first time or maybe even
again on this record I was like porn I
was angry so doc Hanna was like you know
this is your story and as I said there
was definitely a lot of people that
wanted to link was but I was like man
let me just tell it man let me he'll
magic this [__] and you know I'm
not necessarily saying I'm trying to you
know I'm trying to my own thing but just
as far as no huge guest features but who
knows what to expect on the deluxe who
knows will be on the deluxe and but I've
already begun recording the second album
almost set here for the first time
second album the second time work yeah
but recording a couple that never
addressed you know a funny thing is is I
had one song I I send it to him just
like on some friendship [__] my bro
check this out who's also a rapper heard
it and was like this [__] is crazy dawg
he was like it's crazy I you know
whatever and I was like you want to get
on it and he was like shorter than us so
I was saving it for the third for the
second out but I was like [__] it
you know the music's gonna be able for
so yeah be on the deluxe man it's gonna
be crazy
okay okay um you were saying is you're a
part of visionary music group
there's quest and with other dudes named
John Bell Ian John Bell yeah singer yet
it's quite gonna get the AZ slot on your
lil Mac unfortunately nobody there's
like you literally no one on it that's
dope I respect the [__] out of that man
I appreciate it I just did it I just did
it that way cuz like I said it's my
story I just wanna have fun
no that's incredible there's a lot and
like there's a lot of people who could
be like oh no that's a bold move as it
is it's like look man people aren't
gonna buy my album just because of one
verse from somebody else like they're
gonna buy their my house because they
eat a [__] with me or they don't it's
either that good or it's not like I said
Deluxe is um you're the only MC that's
kind of been knew that maybe Kendrick
was someone else rabbit I might say that
really doesn't get compared I don't hear
you getting compared to someone else
that's like a ho G like you know like a
lot of people like triad a lot of your
clan 250 years oh yeah you know there's
just always there's always someone who
has like you know I guess Kendrick some
people be like Kendrick like the new
Mouse or some [__] like that yeah never
really done that with me well I mean
fans but but I guess I read some
horrible comments so what I read some
comments on to Dolph boys a few weeks
back and the fan listen y'all
[__] don't you do doughboys
calm
y'all commenters whatever [__]
websites someone say you sound like MGK
I really that really irked me a bit
no I think it's just a fast flow
there's a world of shout out to two
dopes because that's where I go where do
you go I vote to go to that's right be
trying to what happen when I get yeah
that's what I go looking for all the
music and stuff that's where I'm at
it is I really I really be looking at
comments though cuz I don't give a [__]
like I look at my Twitter feed and like
and like that's what I see so if people
if that if the real fans are like right
hey I don't know about this or this or
that or this is great that that's how I
gauge my [__] I don't gauge watch it all
from people who have like don't give a
[__] yeah I give a [__] I gauge off to
people that I'm actually making the
music for but with that said yeah is
there I know you're making some you're
surviving off hip-hop now which is
always a good thing to be able to do
yeah
have you made a big like first purchase
yet or is that still coming what do you
mean oh you know when everyone gets
their deal they buy their mama [__]
car and they buy a [__] Rover they
buy a chain and I've spent about half a
million dollars since since I got my
deal on one knows
I definitely cuz I I mean I made a lot
more but I'm not trying to study but I'm
saying what I've spent mine what he's
saying is he's a millionaire
this bag of weed definitely that's crazy
no I'm just saying that the music
business is very lucrative that's what
I'm saying yeah but uh I've spent all
all my money like I put half a million
you know into this album and everything
in employing you know the people and
like this is a [__] tour because I
pay for all the [__] out of my pocket
you know what I'm saying like this is
all everything and these tours cost me
six figures and the merchandise and the
money that goes into this and is and is
and it's on a [__] that we have to set
up it comes out of my own pocket so my
biggest my biggest expense was spent on
the fans it wasn't really spent it on
myself you know I got a nice six bedroom
house but I said I [__] rent that you
know I'm not ready once I find a good
woman there's a house in Iowa I'm gonna
yeah yeah once I know who the hell I'm a
marry one day then I'll [__] buy a
house but I'm shelling for quite some
time on that
yeah I did buy a dirt bike I guess ok
Meek Mill that's fun you [__]
yeah I got a dirt bike that's know yeah
that was pretty cool I'm super glad all
my money man I just you know I'll let it
you know go right back into the heads of
the business